so now we've gotten a look at both
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump's
so-called economic plans and in some
cases I'm using those terms pretty
loosely and it turns out that in many
cases there's not much of a difference
between Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump's ideas we'll go through it for
example Hillary Clinton is planning on
spending three hundred billion dollars
over five years on infrastructure both
Trump and Clinton have said they want to
ramp up infrastructure spending now it
could be two different degrees but we
are very quickly Louis talking about
shades of grey on this particular issue
and to get us into this conversation
there are those who say well the fact
that Hillary and Donald are similar on
some of their economic issues is proof
that either Trump is not really
conservative or Hillary is not really
liberal there's another way of looking
at that though which is actually it's
more proof that the the the parameters
for economic policy are so narrow within
mainstream American politics that you're
really only going to see differences in
terms of shades of gray do we want a ten
twelve or fifteen dollar minimum wage do
we want three hundred billion or four
hundred billion on infrastructure
spending etc I think it's more
indicative of that than of anything else
that is true yeah it's also indicative
of just what a disastrous State our
infrastructure is in Metro Fair
acknowledging that and that was one of
Trump's first platforms and one we
agreed with right and that that's when
we thought that Trump might be a
somewhat level-headed guy when he
started talking about infrastructure
spending both Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump are talking about manufacturing
Hillary Clinton has released a ten
billion dollar Make It in America plan
two dozen different programs make that
up some possible boondoggles no doubt
about it but again Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump
both championing manufacturing of course
they're ignoring two really important
realities which we've talked about
number one many of the manufacturing
jobs they claim they will either create
or bring back from other countries no
longer exist
and number two one of the most important
factors in manufacturing jobs is that
automation and artificial intelligence
and robotics are going to continue to
eliminate many of those jobs as we've
talked about no political advantage for
either of them and mentioning that well
and they are both people who over the
course of their lives have seemed to be
not in favor of bringing jobs back to
the US I mean at what point in Hillary
Clinton's career was she some champion
of bringing jobs back to the US and
Donald Trump a guy whose businesses have
exported jobs right yeah there's a
devastating political ad and anti Trump
ad I've seen going around where he's on
the Letterman Show and Letterman is
grilling him and saying oh beautiful
ties were those made Oh bang la - oh
what a great scarf or whatever where's
this made Oh China wow really great for
Chinese jobs right and Trump looks
visibly uncomfortable I don't know if
you've seen that that that commercial
very very good and that gets us to trade
policy right the idea from the Clinton
economic plan is trade policy that puts
us job creation first get tough on China
which Trump has talked about China China
China you probably saw that commercial
that's been going around Hillary Clinton
now saying she's against the
trans-pacific partnership that's good
she was in favor of it for a while but
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
even though Trump you go to these Trump
rallies and the Trump supporters say oh
I like what Trump will do on trade well
what exactly will he do oh well he'll
you know get us out of bad deals or
he'll make good deals or whatever
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
actually a pretty similar message on
trade deals which is their big picture
not opposed to trade deals they just
don't feel that the current trade deals
are the good ones so once again we're
really talking about shades of gray in
many cases with Clinton and Trump on
economics but is you could say like you
were kind of suggesting before that
between Democrats and Republicans it's
all mainstream it's all shades of grey
and the conversation is always kind of
like that